[Music]
what are those pictures
they do such a thorough job of
explaining step by step what we're gonna
start seeing yeah um we've had
Landscaping experiences in the past
um and they were really good but they
just weren't as detailed and to the
process and like pulling us along the
whole process as these guys are so
what's Super Rad is
um you already saw that the excavation
has happened and it's so CUNY because
they'll be like the kids will love to
watch this
so they just explained what the process
is right so we did the excavation
meaning they went and they broke we
broke ground yeah then we did or we we
then they did the plumbing and the steel
reinforcement and then I think they
might be doing electrical
um and then they they just explain
anything after the electrical happens
yeah then they do short shotcrete
oh that's like what's filling it up with
all the concrete and stuff yeah yeah and
then again another process the kids will
love to watch and then it says like
um something about the oh right here you
may want to be at home to watch or
videotape this process that's all we're
gonna do
you know who you're talking to Okay so
as like things get installed like we're
getting like the step by steps yeah
during this process you and I what we
have to do is we have to pick the the
tiles that we want for the the areas
around the pool yeah when she told me
that and I read in an email I was like
but what are the ones because like when
you're in the design process of it
you're just looking at the whole thing
coming together you're not really paying
attention to all the little all the
little details that make that Vision
come to life yeah and they're making it
on a computer so the computer's not
gonna have stocks yeah because it's a
render yeah so it's like a cartoony type
of look that doesn't look very real but
like close enough to where you get an
idea yeah so when she's like you have to
pick the tiles like but wait where does
the tile go which is so cool because
they made these for us oh so we need to
pick tile in these three areas the first
one is going to be the water line here's
a sample photo so this part we have to
pick tile that we want oh that goes
above the water yes we have to pick the
choice of the tile that we want the
grout color so organized that I didn't
even think and then the store and then
she gave us different stores to go to oh
very cool wow and then there's store
hours and stuff yeah so organized I know
so good
um and then we have to pick the barbecue
tile that's going to be yours well not
really I mean I guess I can help yeah
because to me it's all about the whole
thing right so yeah the barbecue tile
top so it's just this part of it yeah
again another sample photo that's so
again we picked the top we want the
grout color because that's so important
um like this this is grout right here so
there's so many different shades you can
go 10 you can go white black there's
just so many different colors so we have
to make sure we pick the right color
that's going to match that tile and then
the final one is going to be for the spa
which is the raised area so the side
Spillway which is here oh okay on the
outside of it yeah and then again we
just write down our choices very cool so
cool I love it it's so comprehensive I
feel so confident going into this
because I'm like I just feel very
empowered I really do and I really do
like working with them so far they've
stuck to their timelines
um and and the reason why I'm just so
surprised is because if you've ever had
any type of like work done around your
house
um maybe we just haven't worked with
professionals but it just always feels
like they're doing their thing and you
just pay them and then they you like
decide uh the big picture and the nest
things are happening things obviously
change and then they kind of pull you in
a little bit and you're just like I
don't know what else is happening and
there's just like people walking in and
out of your house and you're just like
who are these guys they're not the same
guys as the last time so like what is
happening and then at the end you see
your final product and you're like oh
okay cool you know so you're just kind
of like
um put like I don't know you just kind
of keep you're kept out of all the
details where this one it's like I'm not
too much in the details but I'm in the
details enough to know like okay cool
I'm very comfortable that this is not
the thing that's happening
I don't know if that makes sense
you know what's crazy I haven't had a
bloody nose in a long time and
surprisingly I actually get more bloody
noses in La even though Vegas is drier I
don't know what it is maybe because it's
dry as soon as it wants to bleed it
dries it up but it's been extra cold
like it literally snowed uh this week so
maybe that's why it's um I have a blood
nose but anyways that's besides the
point what I wanted to show you guys is
the progress of the pool so the last
Vlog you guys saw you saw them dig the
pool right that's the excavation part
that Jill was talking about and now they
have laid all of the rebar
and you can also see that it's like a
nice structured Square now so that's the
hot tub right there and this is the rest
of the pool and this pool right here
or this portion of the pool right here
is where the kids get to play in that
back long portion is gonna be the lap
pool so the shape of the pool is
extremely unique when we first saw the
render
um like if someone were to pitch to us
like hey um So based off what you guys
want which is you want a place for the
kids to play a place to swim laps and
you also want it to have like this
certain uh like telumi modern
Mediterranean feel I think we should
give you a t-shape for like t-shaped
pool
I don't know about that but good thing
they showed the visual first and that's
also why you hire professionals because
they're better than you at what you can
Envision so now that I look at it I'm
like this this is so amazing it fits the
space so good so let me let me cross
over
so yeah right here it's gonna be seven
feet deep
right so you could do
uh lap swims and then you can also do
the uh what is it duck dies or flip
turns whatever you want to call them and
over here
it starts at around I think three feet
and it goes down to 7p right here but
this whole Splash Zone you could play
and even on the edges like at the corner
we're gonna put little notches so if
people are of the dog AKA Mia gets tired
there's like a little resting spot that
she can have and this whole part right
here is going to be green and it's going
to be a nice play area and to break up
the monotony of this big old wall I
think they're either going to paint it
or put some tile up here and have plants
that go all the way across so this is
what it looks like now
it's gonna be a big pool but also still
have tons of space what are you eating
is that trash Oh my God you little Trash
dog
and up there there's gonna be awning and
that's where the outdoor kitchen is
going to be so yeah all the tile we're
looking at is going to be the tile that
goes along this wall and that hot tub
over there which is what I've been are
you okay oh my God
which is what I've been waiting for for
a long time
monkey where are you going you're so
excited
oh we'd love to say Home Depot
okay monkey
so you know what this is
Ikea that's for you
do you even know what it is
what is it I don't know okay look I have
to build it still but where's the
picture it's this
look at that a big desk so you can do
all your arts and crafts and use
permanent
oh no that's a project that we're gonna
do on the weekend that's a project you
know the poster board project no no
that's not it this is this is a desk
because you know how like when I don't
let you've drawn here with the permanent
marker because it's permanent marker who
got him permanent markers his cool dad
it's gone I cleaned it pretty good
um but yeah I don't let him do anything
here or that because this is permanent
markers
um
so I got you your own desk okay the
other thing I got you this one's a cool
project
is this box and what's cool about this
box where's the picture
it looks like this you could put all
your Treasures in there
and you can color it with whatever paint
or color or stickers you want what about
surfies sure anything you want sure okay
the other one is I got you stuff for
your bed so your bedroom okay then
so cool and I got you this one because
you keep it on the bed so when you pee
be on the bed it doesn't mess up your
mattress
sheets
these little acorns
what do you say
thank you you're welcome hoodies
while my Bear's building the desk
I'm in charge of some dinner and I just
want to share with you guys sometimes
there are some steals at Albertsons so
always always stay on the lookout I've
been seeing these all over so I bought a
ton of them this strip loin cut has an
insane nutrition facts look 25 grams of
protein with only four grams of fat it's
so rare to find like five to one protein
of fat ratios so this is a serving size
it's four ounces this one is how many
ounces
this one is it's a little bit over a
half a pound so that makes it probably
eight to ten ounces which means there's
50 grams of protein in this okay 50 to
60 with less than 10 grams of fat which
is insane and it's super flavorful I
bought a first batch and then I ended up
stocking up like crazy so I have this
here and in our freezer in the garage
and to hook up taika with
um
his dinner remember the beef stew that I
made in the last vlog
well that is so hearty and has a lot of
good nutrition so that's what he's gonna
eat we got the white rice always on Deck
because that's how you make food fast
and then we got
um the beef stew right here and the
ground beef and Mia always wants a piece
so we got this bad boy right here
so I can heat this thing up with all the
onions carrots mushrooms all the good
stuff
in for taika in less than a minute
that's why I love having meals prepped
because when you're a busy parent you
got a lot of stuff to do
so the last thing I want to do is take
forever on every single meal because
eating three meals a day a day and it's
an hour each time that's three hours but
look at that look at all this hearty
food heirloom carrots beef broth
mushrooms garlic all the good stuff
Mia wants all the smoke all the time
okay so this is kind of like a little
art desk
he scared her
um this is what it's eventually gonna
look like I don't know what I was
thinking but I was like
this will be chill I didn't even
consider that it needed any type of
assembly like I don't know what I was
thinking maybe I was just like Bart's
got this
no problem yeah so I'm building it
was happening
and this is way more complicated than I
ever imagined it would be
what is all this look at this
dude
what
okay well
we'll figure it out
you can't go wrong with Ikea right or
should these things are on the outside
okay that's gonna be interesting
holy crap holy bajibas okay
we'll do one step at a time that's a
first though this right here is the
first time I've ever seen Ikea number
anything and I'm already missing three
what happened to three
[Music]
okay that's not it that's three
oh no there it is
okay
I think we'll be all right I think I can
make it I think I could do it foreign
that's probably where the seizure
started
all right so as I'm making the steaks
I've come across my new favorite way to
season it's pretty simple just black
pepper
some sea salt
and onion you guys see that theme
I talked about onions in the last Vlog
I've been loving the way that onions and
beef taste and it really brings out the
beefiness
so I just seasoned it and I also
seasoned the sides too
just to really get that flavor in so I'm
also going to show you guys this new
cooking technique that Nadine put me on
and I've been cooking honestly like the
most perfect steaks ever because what I
do now is I cook one side
take it off just to sear let the pan
heat up and then cook the other side so
without letting the pan cool down
because usually if you put it down you
know the meat's cold it cools the pan
down then you flip it over so the other
side here isn't as good now both sides
here is really good and then you get
like a perfect medium rare Shots Out
shout out to the name he's the one that
put me on this technique I'll show you
guys
all right so you see this
I'm searing one side
got it on there for about 30 seconds now
and usually I would have
flipped it over but instead
I take it off
put it here and then
let the pan
re-cook that oil bring it up to Temp
because the minute the meat touches it I
just put a little more oil the minute
the meat touches it it cools the panda
so now I let
the pan keep that oil back up
and then I'll get an insane sear so now
I put on the other side
look at that look how good that Sears
just for my 30 seconds
right there
and I usually try to keep the fat side
in the center so the center of the tent
is the hottest so I try to keep the fat
always closest to the Heat
watch watch how this turns out
or it's not the only one killing the
game at creating stuff taika is creating
what are you doing are you eating paper
what the [__] okay so you're destroying
stuff
what oh my God okay then what happened
but why use your mouth instead of your
hands
it's funnier huh because it has shut ah
yeah thanks you got canine okay so while
papa is creating taika is destroying I
am building
um so far so good this is where I'm at
I'm only on step
okay I just completed step four out of
holy [__] okay I don't even know why I
vlogged this I didn't know that there
was literally 28 steps okay I need to
speed it up I thought I was doing great
but yeah I should have known that when I
saw the zillion pieces that remain to
put on this damn desk all right whatever
I'll be back so while I'm cooking the
steak I hooked up taika's meal just from
these three quick ingredients got the
ground beef got the veggies got the beef
broth at the bottom got the white rice
so all I got to do now is get some uh
paper towel wet it put this in the
microwave for a good two minutes and his
is ready to go
foreign
[Music]
steaks are done
just letting it rest
got about one minute left that's very
very important a lot of people when they
cook steak they take it off and they cut
immediately that's how all the juices
come out so you want it to rest and let
it soak its own juices back up so that's
why I have it just sitting here
um
yeah she's waiting for her dinner huh
no
oh my God
[Music]
all right family dinner time you like
the mashed cauliflower it's pretty good
I don't like the cauliflower much
but that's pretty good yeah I made like
a kind of Cajun seasoning so this one is
just meat and just uh veggies please dig
into the steak and let you know how it
is yeah yeah I hope I did wow see that
you're getting better let me sear and
pink
perfect
and Mr Monkey Man got you see all the
carrots I put in there I know you love
carrots you see all that put all the
carrots in there
yeah
so we all got a CUNY family meal
together
[Music]
all right tell me this isn't a perfectly
cooked steak look at that nobody down
perfectly seared you see that
dude perfectly seared
only pink damn play a player
oh
he's like awkward if you only knew
whoa look at the desk is almost done
nothing's big huh it's as big as you
dude
you're gonna have so much fun on this
desk
you have summer art projects
what the
yeah
okay let's go to bed mister
[Laughter]
I always doubt myself but I got it done
looks great oh it looks really cute yeah
and you can like bring it down too
oh this is
the back here
oh nice
and then you buy like a roll yeah so he
can like draw on or you can just pull it
out like a picture paper it's gonna be
perfect
perfect imagine the Aesthetics of the
house too is it yeah it's like wood and
white
is it no
yeah
it looks great Mama good job
all right so now it's time for me I
gotta go outside and go for a walk I'm
still on my get lean tip even though I'm
in my get strong program because I need
to get my keep my weight down because
I'm competing at 183 pounds which is 83
kilos
for those of you guys that are wondering
like why would anybody compete at like a
weird odd number like that it's because
it's kilos converted to pounds
and uh it's freezing like last night I
went out with just sweatpants like this
oh yeah by the way these new uh Barbara
Burger joggers I went out with these bad
boys but it's so freaking cold to win
it's 31 yeah the wind goes right through
my pants
um so
I'm actually bringing out the big guys
the snow pants snow jacket
have this on and if this doesn't work
then I have my balacava
which is like the thing that looks like
what bank robbers wear but this covers
the whole face if it's up warm enough so
I can get stay as protected I should
probably get gloves too because yeah
last night the minute the wind blew it
felt like I wasn't wearing anything it
just went right through everything but
I'm gonna go do my nightly walk
8 35 should be back by like nine nine
ten nine fifteen right in time to
make some babies with that lovely letter
right there
took a shower
ended up ending the day with
thirteen Thousand Steps my average is
twelve thousand
this has been helping me keep my weight
down
because what I realized is I'd rather do
more work so I can eat more
otherwise
um if I have like a hard cut like 1500
calories a day
um my appetite's too big so everyone has
a different uh
a tolerance for how much you need to eat
how much work they can put out but
ultimately you need to be in a caloric
deficit so whether your caloric deficit
is a negative 300 or negative 500 you
got to find your way to get there so you
could either be someone that consumes
two thousand but Burns 2500 or consumes
1500 and burn two thousand and for me
I'd rather
eat a little bit more burn a little bit
more and now it's a time for me to go to
bed and uh see you guys tomorrow good
night